the lobby of Ramsey solutions John and
Mary are with us hey guys how are you hi
Dave we're great dude welcome welcome
where you guys from st. Louis Missouri
welcome well we're honored to have you
in Nashville thank you and you're here
to do a debt free scream yes sir how
much have you paid off $90,000 Wow how
long did that take six months good job
man that's fast making what kind of
money not just north of a hundred okay
so how do you pay off ninety in six
months if you're just north of hundred
you must have sold something big we did
not okay
something's wrong with the math what'd
you do wait we don't die our whole life
insurance plan
yes okay all right and how much was that
fifty fifty nine thousand okay very good
all right so then you you cash float the
other 30,000 or so yes sir okay that's
doable in six months with that income
now I can breathe okay good
I get my math right we could breathing
out to kill the Mayo there you go kills
a math nerd to get it okay great this is
awesome so tell me the story what
happened what caused you to do all this
about a year ago I guess a little over I
started me a new job and within the same
field and one of the guys was talking
about you and he said you should see
this guy this Dave Ramsey and Sulu he
lent us his Financial Peace University
and we started to do our departments
started to do financial piece Friday oh
wow where we watched a a show mm-hmm and
then I tore my rotator cuff and was out
for eight weeks but because I get I had
the stick then we took a trip and we did
all nine lessons on a trip okay we took
my laptop and just watch them all okay
just boom just like that okay and that's
the way we kept saying oh hey wait we
can do this this is gonna be cool we can
do this this is not gonna be that hard
made you believe yes sir
yeah very cool so you say all right
we're gonna get rid of what you
understood the whole life you said we're
gonna get our term insurance and get rid
of the whole life how long had you had
the whole life policy he had it since
well since I just
25 and I'm 53 now okay so that was a bit
of a decision then wasn't it yeah I I
have to look and got mad because uh how
much money had lost is he giving it to
the whole life people yeah and I guess I
was looking at ROI yeah kind of looked
at that like wow I should have had that
money instead of that yeah this sucks
yeah absolutely
Wow very cool so you cash that in once
you get your term insurance in place
that pays off 60 what kind of debt was
your ninety thousand we had his car and
we both have a student loan I am a nurse
so I have loan forgiveness so we pay off
her house instead of paying off my
student loan oh we have adopted that as
our new house payment I love it just
went ahead and paid off the house very
just like that yeah so his car his
student loan we had a HELOC get rid of
that and so we just started the snowball
as we were learning in the lessons as we
were driving from st. Louis to Iowa and
through Illinois and back yeah and
listen to online lessons how's it feel
not having a house payment that's a big
relief I'm telling was tired of paying
$400 a month to the bank so it's gone
it's in a pocket now instead of bears
absolutely so what's the house worth now
about 120 hundred 40 somewhere in there
excellent very cool she have no house
payment no that $100,000 in income
life is good congratulations y'all it's
awesome so when people ask how did you
do that what do you tell them we tell
them the key to getting out of debt is
I'm a bit of the master mm-hmm and so I
I he'd come home from work and I'd be
going Irene the spreadsheet today and
he'd be like oh I need I need to run
some numbers and he's like Oh knock
yourself out and she started showing me
those numbers all I totally count yeah
yeah he gets paid hourly I'm on salary
so he really really kicked it in I can
do this over time I can do that and so
he just kept I call him did that
snowballing fool and he would just bring
it home and
I'm working I go in at 3 o'clock in the
morning and work 12 hours and a couple
of days a week and wow he really really
kicked it in Wow it was awesome
nothing like hard work to bring in the
bacon I love it they did it that's great
congratulations you guys I'm so proud of
you and your son and your daughter's
name and ages
this is Taylor she's 14 she'll be 15 on
the 21st mm-hmm and this is joy he's 12
he'll be 13 in February
awesome very cool and we have my from my
first marriage I have a 29 year old
whoo-hoo because of what we were doing
she's debt-free as well in fact if
you're showing the pictures she's in
there
okay a single picture okay the one
vehicle that we keep showing that has
the two selfies
we just cash float his middle garage so
he could have something to haul his
tools around in nice I like it well very
cool you guys congratulations very well
done all right John and Mary in the team
st. Louis Missouri ninety thousand bucks
paid off in six months making a hundred
thousand a year with hard work and math
nerd spreadsheets count it down let's
hear a great debt free scream three two
one way to go you guys very very very
well done